along me amaz border with China tens of
thousands of people live in displacement
camps distressed and poverty-stricken
many find solace in the cheapest and
most readily available drug heroin
sender pan has been on and off the drug
for years when conflict flared eighty
years ago her mother fled China
and left panel own with no money I
became a drug addict because of me
actually I have quit once before a long
time ago but I came back to use drugs
again it's all because of me
my heart's not strong to say no to drugs
pan is recovering at Patterson
Rehabilitation Center run by the Kachin
Independence Organization near the
capital laser women are some of the most
vulnerable as there are not enough jobs
for them and prostitution is rife
but drug users come from all walks of
life during the initial dry out days
somewhere these chains to prevent them
from running away we lived in the IDP
camp near China's border and there are
many drug dealers and users there when
we hear people in the IDP camps are
addicted to drugs we investigate and
find out who is using them suspected
uses in IDP camps are asked to provide
urine tests to show of their use of
drugs if they fail they're forced to
come into the center many fear going
back home we're at $1 a hit heroin is
not only affordable but it's difficult
to escape the equation can bars almost
every house and every villager selling
the drugs they sell on the streets and
alleyways people are selling drugs
because of the conflict the conflict
began in 1962 when the military took
control of the region a ceasefire was
broken eight years ago when Myanmar
forces and the Kachin Independence Army
fought for control with talks stalled
there's uncertainty over who will
controls state in the future which could
continue to have consequences for the
many vulnerable people living here Laura
Berta Manley al-jazeera